right last time i had the most amazing
chicken wings was with the incredible
shawn evans
and thankfully 75 million of you tuned
in to watch that amazing program so
thank you
so i'm going to show you how to perfect
the most amazing wing this time we're
going to take it up a notch
and make those wings incredibly
delicious so
beautiful wings make sure they're full
of flesh sometimes you get a little bit
chef if you want with a presentation
bone but
they need seasoning okay so in here i've
got a little bit of garlic powder
a little bit of salt and nicely dust
those wings okay now from there
let's get a bit heat nice
spoon of beautiful smoked paprika okay
now what does that do that literally
just starts
to give these wings a lovely coat and
be generous okay give that a nice mix
the salt the garlic powder and
that amazing smoked paprika that
smokiness gives them the sort of
richness but without being too spicy
now from there once they're beautifully
mixed
wash their hands now once it's all
nicely mixed in
just do another light dusting there as
well just on top
garlic powder and the salt over there
get a pan nice hot pan bring it up to
temp
a little tablespoon of oil
literally in with your wings now
at this point we need to sear them okay
and get
[Music]
get [ __ ] up
[Music]
secret here is give a really nice sear
okay bit of butter
corn down that gets it really nice and
golden brown and just roll them around
quickly
now you can see what's happening to the
wings that really nice
dark caramelized take
those spices butter adds the flavor a
little bit more richness
helps to cool down the wings
beautiful so this bit here with all the
butter will have a really nice seasoning
look so what happens now is that the
actual flesh starts to move down the
bone
and it almost becomes like a little
lollipop which
is great for picking up don't worry
about that flesh and that skin sliding
down
now clearly we've got a great sear
from there one more little toss
and a nice seasoning of black pepper
open up the top of the pepper mill and
get that nice large
cracked pepper in there i love sauteing
chicken wings when they're
sort of nice and hot they take the
pepper so much easier
as opposed to putting on the beginning
look
beautiful now
once we sit in all that beautiful spice
and those wings have been dredged in the
paprika the garlic powder the salt
okay as that starts to froth it tells
you time for the oven
375 fahrenheit for 15 minutes
that smell is incredible now have a look
at them
so this is where the magic starts you
can see the actual
skin and flesh has sort of slid down the
bone
and you can tell they're cooked
hey they've obviously got but most
importantly the
bone is nice and clean now from there
[Music]
just in now
to glaze them first of all
take a spoon and just take
a large tablespoon of that beautiful
juice from there get your hot sauce
give it a really good shake as you know
it settles in the bottle get a really
good shake
and then just gently drip that over
there
but how do we get them nice and glossy
kind of put that nice little glaze on
there
get a nice knob of butter and literally
put the butter in there your tongs
and then literally one more little
tablespoon
over now give them a really nice mix
and what's happening now is the butter
is melting
okay and they get really nice
and glazed and look
beautiful mix that up
now you don't want too much hot sauce on
there because you always go back for
seconds but
the secret is to beautifully
mix them up
look the butter
beautifully melts gives that a really
nice
beautiful glaze and watch the wings
in
peaceful and there
you've got the most amazing wings
and then you have the most amazing
hot spicy wings ready for another 75
million views
[Music]
you